okay welcome back our next speaker is a
comic a teacher thank you
so I will continue the controversial
themes of beyond worst case and also
started by early but I go talk about a
little bit different approach to beyond
worst case complexity about instant
stability or perturbation resilience so
this approach got popular recently and
my talk is based on joint works with
Harris Angelou dicus Julian McCullough
chip and are even done Vijay Raghavan
and the first let me I give you some
motivation for studying beyond
worst-case analysis so as I mentioned in
his previous work one of the motivations
for studying beyond worst-case analysis
is that sometimes we can use techniques
from algorithms that are developed or
designed for big on your skis instances
then later on to attack your skis
instances a kind of another reason why
we may study beyond worst-case analysis
is that sometimes I mean in practice we
need to solve NP hard problems and
actually often we need to solve NP hard
problems and the first lick can design
polynomial time algorithms that always
solve such problems but maybe we don't
even care so in practice we only need to
solve really old problems so instances
that come from real world and we want to
design algorithms that work well in
practice and often that's possible so
often heuristics that people use in the
real world work pretty well and they
work much better than what theoretically
possible for worst case instances and so
what we want to understand is why it
happens so that's the question we want
to ask your scientists as sort of as
engineers we want to design algorithms
that work in the real world and we want
to have provable guarantees for such
but of course to study in the real world
we need some kind of model of real world
or of real the old instances and there
are many different models of real gold
instances and all of them have some
advantages and disadvantages and we
talked about various generative random
semi random models I will talk about
slightly different a model called
stability and I think that's important
to have various models because for some
problems one type of models works for
some other problems
another type of models words and even
depending on the applications depending
on the source of data we may need to use
different models so what is what I'm
going to talk today is a sumption called
instant stability of perturbation
resilience so these two terms mean
exactly the same but they give them a
different context for historical reasons
and I will demonstrate algorithms for
stable and perturbation resilient
problems on k-means comedian problems
mark Scott and multi way cut problems so
the first two problems are clustering
problems and the second two problems are
sort of graph partitioning or
chamilitary optimization problems so
what I'm going to do I will I give two
algorithms that find exact solution for
these and Picard problems is humid that
the instances for this problems are too
stable or too perturbation resilient and
I will remind you the definitions of
these problems and they will also give
you the definition of stability and
perturbation resilience in a moment so
let me first remind you what the key
means and comedian problems are so
there's a clustering problem so they
have they are given a metric space X
with a distance function D and our goal
is to partition a metric space into K
pieces into
kay clusters she once ever see key and
in every cluster pica Center CI so as to
minimize the sum of distances from every
point to the closest Center in the
comedian problem and the sum of squared
distances from every point to the
closest Center in key means problem so
he often these problems are studied when
X is embedded into the Euclidean space
and so the Dometic isn't used by the
Euclidean space and in this case people
usually pick centers from the Euclidean
space itself not from X so for the
purpose of this talk we assume that we
only give an a metric space X so it's
not embedded anywhere and so if we must
pick centers from the set X only so all
centers must belong to X so these are
the problems the multi way cut problem
which Roy talked yesterday is the
following problem we are given a graph G
and they are given a set of terminals T
1 etc TK and our goal is to partition
our graph into pieces so that every
piece contains exactly one terminal and
the goal is to minimize the weight of
cut edges so we will deal with key
I mean comedian problems and multi y
multi way cut problem in this talk and
now let me give you the main definition
that we are going to study the
definition of regional stability and
perturbation resilience so consider an
arbitrary problem clustering locomotor
optimization problem and let's look at
an instance of this problem we say that
I prime is a gamma perturbation of this
instance if in I prime all parameters I
perturb by a factor at most gamma so
what does it mean for our two problems
so for multi very cut problem
any perturbation i prime of our original
instance eyes is defined on the same
graph G it is a set of set of terminals
but with a new set of edge weights w
prime e so every W prime E is sandwiched
between the original weight W E and
gamma times W e for questioning problems
a perturbation is the perturbation of
the metric so in your instances get
defined on the same set of points but
within you distance function G prime
such that the distance between any two
points U and V is sandwiched between the
original distance between U and V and
gamma times that distance now what we
require is that we say that an instance
is gamestate gamma stable if for any
perturbation of our instance the optimal
solution does not change so the optimal
solution of any perturbation is the same
as the optimal solution to the original
instance and there are some subtlety and
this definition and I will discuss them
later on so when we talk about
clustering I will point out to some
subtleties and what it exactly means
that the solution does not change so
let's look at this definition so if
gamma is small this definition is fairly
big so it means that there is only so
essentially one stability means that
there is a unique optimal solution and
therefore kind of pretty much any
instance is one stable at least if you
slightly perturbed officiants that the
solution will be unique so pretty much
any any any instances one stable to be
condition as gamma grows this condition
gets stronger and stronger
so in general of course we want gamma to
be maybe 1 plus Epsilon so this is most
reasonable assumption
and those you may think think that this
condition is very strong because it it
said that the solution doesn't change at
all so there is a more natural
definition a weaker definition of big
stability where we say that the when we
perturb our coefficients the optimal
solution may change but it doesn't
change much but they won't talk about
this definition today why I ran the
model I don't know so I don't know
whether if you take some distribution
some kind of GNP distribution something
else whether you'll get stable instances
probably you can come up these
parameters that will generate such
instances but yeah I'm not sure about
this okay so so this is the definition
any questions about it and now probably
you're curious why why do we care about
stability why can we assume that in
practice we have stable instances and
the answer is that usually when we look
for some so you should you're looking
for a solution that kind of stands out
among others and this is the solution
that will be optimal in fact if you
solve a clustering problem usually you
don't care as is about the objective
function so you you want to find a good
clustering of your dataset and then you
try different objectives do you find an
objective that helps you to find the
clustering you're looking for and so
what happens if your instance is not
stable so if your instance is not stable
you don't have obvious some noise in
your data and depending on that noise
you will get very different clusterings
so in some sense if the instances is not
stable then you even don't care about
solving the problem because the solution
you're going to find won't be relevant
to you so in a way we only care about
solving a clustering problem if the
Stinson's table of course this condition
might be a little bit strong so it's
kind of only approximation to what we
want but this is idea what why we care
about stability
maybe I we need to slightly relax the
conditions of the stability but that's a
and that's a good open question actually
how to to make it a little bit more
realistic but the idea is that if you
have a non stable instance that people
get very different solutions because of
mine are variances in your data and
those solution want this also the
solutions you are looking for okay so
let me give you a normal view over your
results and kind of history behind this
question the notion of stability was
introduced by Billu and lineal in 2010
in the context of discrete optimization
and specifically max cut problem and
then it was adapted for clustering
problems by Avaya C Blum and chef it in
2012 and so they studied Kaminsky median
and key center problems there was some
related notions were somewhat different
and I'm not going to talk about them by
asteroid Cherubini Schumann and Swami
and Vulcan Blum and Gupta so what's
known about clustering so for clustering
a viable arm and chef at first proposed
an algorithms that find the exact
solution for three stable instances of
key center key means comedian and some
other problems
the result was improved by Balkan and
Leone for gamma approximately two point
forty one and then back on a shuttle AB
and white gave an exact algorithm for
somatic and the symmetric version of the
key Center problem where gamma is 2 and
here is to get in asked Everest and Yuri
we gave an algorithm for two stable
instances of k-means and comedian and
this is the algorithm I'm going to talk
about today and so
know that this result of Bakken cattle
web and white is a zone is essentially
tight that's what they showed and the
other results might be tight or may not
be tight so they're tight under some
other assumption which is called central
proximity and they will talk about this
assumption so it's not clear whether
this result can be a problem that again
an open question
so what's known so with this resilience
do you still only restrict to the
modified inputs still this metric or
does it have two things that are some
questions so you can restrict it only to
be in a metric I will talk about this
but yes you can distinct that only to be
a metric in the original definition the
perturbation could be an arbitrary set
of distances not necessarily satisfy
triangle inequality so for Camila
optimization below a lineal in the
original work showed how to solve
exactly max instances max cut instances
with gamma equal C times M so this is a
very strong assumption instability and
then they slightly improved it in the
work with Daniela and sax - gamma equal
to C times square root of M and here is
the number of vertices so the
exponentially improved that busywork
individually and aravindan - gamma
equals square root log and log Lagaan
and we kind of showed that this might be
optimal so he gave some evidence not
very strong evidence may be that this is
the optimal bound so in a way this
result might be a little bit
unsatisfactory because still gamma is
pretty large so generally we want
gamma to be much much smaller but
situation is much better for a multi-way
card so in the same Berkley
gave an exact algorithm for gamma equal
to 4 and the invariant work with Harris
and urea we improved it to 2 minus 2
over K and if I have time I will tell
you a little bit about this algorithm as
well but but now let me show you you an
algorithm an algorithm for clustering
problems Kaminsky median and actually
many other problems so here is a plan
first I will prove that gamma
perturbation resilience imply another
property called gamma Center proximity
and then we will see that if our
instance satisfies two perturbation
resilience and chance to center
proximity then the optimal solution legs
looks very nice
so each cluster in the optimal solution
is the factory of the minimum spanning
tree and using these two property we
will design an algorithm so the
algorithm works as follows so it takes
the metric space then finds the minimum
spanning tree and in this minimum
spanning tree using dynamic programming
it rakaat recovers the cluster CI so
that's going to be the plan and ok
the first step in our plan is we need to
show that our instance is two Center
satisfies two Center proximity with the
center proximity we say that an
instances satisfies to some gamma Center
proximity if for any cluster CI and
every point P in that cluster the
distance to the to any other center to
any center outside of its own cluster is
at least distance gamma is lesser than
the distance to its own Center by a
factor at least gamma
again so we take any center CI any point
P and look at the distance from P to any
center
than its own Center and this distance
must be gamma times greater than the
distance to the port to its own center
see I so this is a property and okay so
now I'm going back to today with
question so what is perturbation
resilience so in perturbation resilient
we say that any perturbation of our
metric should keep our optimal solution
in act so it shouldn't change the
optimal clustering and here I need to
point out that it shouldn't change the
clusters but it can change centers if we
say that any perturbation doesn't change
centers as well it will be too strong
condition and in a way all the result
will would be meaningless so an
important point is that any perturbation
doesn't change the cluster but that may
change centers another subtle point
whether the co metric D prime should
satisfy triangle inequality and then the
original instance in the original
definition it didn't have to but we put
another constraint on it the D prime
must be an metric and this of course
makes the definition only weaker and so
if an instance satisfy the original
definition it will also satisfy the new
definition so we will work with this
condition so wide let's prove that
perturbation resilience implies Center
proximity and the it is as follows so
let's assume that this is not the case
then they exist a point P and center C J
such that the distance from P switch to
CJ is less than gamma times distance
from P to CI let's perturb the the
metric and decrease the distance from P
to CJ to be equal to the distance from P
to CI
since this ratio was less than gamma
this is the gamma perturbation of this
distance and less much change other
distances so if he could make such a
perturbation then we will be done
because we know that our instances
perturbation resilient it means that the
optimal clustering doesn't change and it
means that the distance and it means
that P still belong to the same cluster
as before we which implies that the
distance from P to see I is less than
the distance from P to CJ otherwise we
could move me to another cluster and we
would get another optimal solution there
are several problems here so one
solution one problem is that when we
decrease the distance from P to CG then
the then it may affect some other
distances right so if you only change
the distance then the in geometric one
such as petrol triangle Nakota
so what we do here is that we decrease
this age the the length of the edge from
P to CG kind of in the complete graph on
our metric space and then we take
shortest path metric on the graph so if
you take the metric closer and of course
by the definition satisfies all triangle
coaches so now you have another problem
so once we make this a closure the the
distances within every cluster means
somehow change at least a priori and
because of that the Centers of the
clusters may shift and so the previous
argument doesn't work so it turns out
however that the distances in the
clusters within the cluster CI and CJ do
not change so let's see why so let's
pick any two points U and V NCI and
let's look what the distance between U
and V in the new metric so this is a
minimum between the original distance
between U and V and the kind of shortcut
taken over this age
PGG so it's minimum between GV and the
distance from you gu from you to P then
the new length of the HP CJ
and the length of the edge between V and
CG let's let's look at this new distance
it's low bounded by the length of the
path from u to peer then from P to CI
and from CITV why because the distance
from P to CJ is equal to the distance
from PCI and the distance from D to C is
less than the distance from B to C G
because Li belongs to CI and CI its own
Center for veer right so the distance
from D to C I is smaller so we got that
the distances in CI didn't change and
similarly the distances in CJ didn't
change so it means that the Centers of
the classes remained the same and so the
argument I gave you before works now so
since P belongs to the class this year
the distance from P to CI in the new
metric is less than the distance from P
to CG so if you prove the statement now
we need to show that the optimal
clusters form sub trees in our minimum
spanning tree so the picture looks like
this so why does it happen we will use a
lemma from a BF that says to proximity
implies that for every cluster CI and
for every u this and the distance from
you to its own Center is less than or
equal to the distance from you to any
other vertex not from any other point
naught naught in this in the class
crazy.i so before that we had the
condition that the distance from you to
its own center had to be less less than
or equal to half of the distance from
you to any other center and here the
kind of relaxes condition so if we are
interested in the distance from u to any
other vertex but we lose the factor of
1/2 and this lemma is easily approved by
applying triangle inequalities so I will
skip it and now what what we have so we
need to show that
for any vertex you the unique shortest
path in the MHD from you to its own
center ci lies within the cluster right
so assume that this is not the case and
that there is an edge there is the
vertex u such that the path from u to CI
leaves the cluster CI and let's assume
that u v is the edge that crosses the
boundary of the cluster and then of
course what you can say is that by this
property the the length of the edge V V
is less than or equal to the length of
the edge from u to V I and because of
this we can replace in the MST the edge
UV by the edge
UCI and this will only decrease the
length of the MST and we get a
contradiction so this showed this
statement and now we need somehow so
what what we now know is that all
clusters of optimal clusters are sub
trees of the MST and to recover these
clusters we use dynamic programming so
for every sub tree we just will store
the price of dividing that sub tree into
G pieces and this should be a little bit
careful with the top part of the every
sub tree sort of this cluster which you
belong to may have a center outside of
the tree so we will add another
parameter so what will store this for
every u J and C we will keep the cost of
breaking the sub tree rooted at you in G
pieces given that the cluster which he
belongs to should have a center in C so
this is our dynamic program and it's not
hard to show that by filling the GP
table bottom-up we can solve the DPM so
if you need to consider various cases
different subtrees of you belong to the
same to the same cluster as you or
different clusters is the same one of
them is the theme that is not etc and
you can write a recurrence like this
which which is correct but probably you
don't have time to to fully understand
what's written here and sort of this
solve the problem so again what we
showed is that the elder image which is
often called single linkage algorithm
that was used from the sixties together
with in your dynamic program solves the
k-means problem and comedian problem is
human that instances are too stable of
course this this assumption of to
stability is very strong so how much
damage oh okay so let me then give a
summary so I showed you how to solve the
problem clustering problem for two
perturbation resilient problems there is
another algorithms that solve a
multi-way cut problem and the algorithm
itself is very easy so if we just write
the standard LP relaxation for multi we
cut 300 for multi way cut and so but and
it turns out that if the instance is too
stable then the solution is integral so
we just output the integral solution
that's easy
the interesting part of course how to
prove that that that instance is stable
and surprisingly we need to design an
approximation algorithms for the purpose
of the proof that kind of is the witness
of stability of the optimal LP solution
and they also showed various negative
results and so I think the most
interesting open question is what's the
right definition of stability how much
we can relax it
and whether this assumption is kind of
realistic and to what extend the okay so
for clustering right so for multi way
cart it's an LPS so it has the same
approximation reaches the best algorithm
for a multi-way cut for stability here
so it I think you can come up with
pretty bad examples good question I mean
there is of course a three Tyrael
think you know try to write two
algorithms and take the best but if you
care about a more natural algorithm I
don't know but then I think about this
algorithm is actually that such
algorithm is just I used in practice I
mean not exactly like this but but the
idea is called single linkage and single
linkage is used in practice even though
I think yeah it's very easy to come up
with bad instances you can kind of come
up with some kind of bridges pretty much
for any instance if you you let me add a
little bit of outliers I can fail the
forgiving so it seems that you're stuck
in a conundrum and then you can test
whether it input is too perturbation
related so it would be nice if on the
flip side you actually could actually
have a certificate of optimality at
least on ER an instance by instance
basis which it doesn't seem you have
let's say for the
the plus three do you think there's any
hope let's say even just perfectly I
hope in fact what we want we want to so
called robust algorithms so what we want
is that either the algorithms solve the
problem exactly or finds the good
approximation depending on the current
is or it says okay this instance is not
stable so the main base time gray area
where the algorithm still solve that but
the instance is not stable that's fine
and for our competitor optimization
problems of course the algorithm is like
that because it solves LT and it says
okay if the LT is integral then I give
you the solution so obviously the
solution is optimal for clustering yeah
we tried to come up with robust
algorithms as well so far we don't know
how to get a robust algorithm
although
is there a smooth degradation so like
like okay because you're saying we want
to stable but suppose I give you 1.5
stable maybe don't give me exact answer
but
probably no no I don't think so it is
not for plastering no not for this
clustering algorithm I think thank us
again